est-ce que l'épidémie une épidémie c'est
toujours propice aux rumeurs
alors c'est propice parce que c'est une
crise mais l'épidémie s'est jamais
quelque chose d'agréable c'est quelque
chose au contraire extrêmement
désagréable et donc on est dans une
crise ont qui plus est aujourd'hui
inédite elle est mondiale et d'une
dureté incroyable donc là on oui on peut
absolument répondre par l'affirmative à
l'idée que les épidémies créer les
rumeurs ou en tout cas les les favorise
maintenant il faut s'en méfier c'est à
dire ce n'est pas parce que nous sommes
en période de crise qu'il n'y a que des
rumeurs qui circulent en fait c'est tout
qui sait que c'est toutes les
informations circulent de manière
décupler comme jamais on a même reçu ce
qu'ils ont quand même assez rare un sms
du gouvernement tous les tous les
citoyens français laurent travaux ou à
peu près donc on voit que la crise est
un moment qu'on peut qualifier d'infos
des milk
c'est un néologisme paquet qui est qui
et qui n'est en ce moment c'est en même
temps que la crise a surgissement de
milliers de milliards d'informations y
compris des rumeurs c'est à dire y
compris un certain lot d'informations
qui circulent de manière virale de
manière incontrôlée très rapidement et
qui frappe l'imagination
parce que elle s'oppose ou qu'on arrive
à les qualifier de fausses le problème
c'est qu'il ya plein d'informations en
même temps qu'ils circulent tout comme
tonton qu'on n'est pas trop trop les la
capacité réelle
enfin et qu'on ne qualifie pas de
rumeurs qu'on va simplement qualifié d'
information bizarre d'information à
vérifier et en fait c'est l'ensemble qui
fait cette info des mystères une
surgissement extrêmement brutal
d'information de rumeurs de mensonges de
manipulations de fait qu news enfin tout
tout tout cet ensemble de mots qu'on a
pour désigner des
bon des bribes de récits sur la réalité
qui reste à prouver
parce que on aimerait bien savoir ce que
c'est que la réalité la réalité d'une
épidémie en particulier les changeantes
[Musique]